[Music]
what's up nick what's up today's gonna
be an interesting day
i've been working out of this building
for the past 10 years
look at that neck
i'm stuck making the money thanks for
making me pay taxes
so many memories so many mems and i
think today is the day that i'm gonna be
leaving corridor i'm gonna fill the guys
in and i figure you guys should know why
as well
this decision was not an easy one
it's very scary anxiety-inducing
some would say crazy for leaving a dream
job
[Applause]
this job is literally the best i get
paid really well here it's very fun
working here i
learn new stuff every day
i love everyone that works here they
love me like what more could i ask for
dude that's the dream that's the dream
job that's everything i feel like things
will be a lot easier if this job sucks
if my boss is sucked and you dread every
single day coming to work quitting your
full-time job might be a little easier
maybe maybe here at corridor i love
being able to teach i love being able to
educate and help others and i realized
i've never been as good as i am now at
visual effects basically last year i
started doing live streams on my youtube
channel and they were just cinema 4d vfx
live streams it's been six years since i
posted a video six years since i posted
a video on my channel i am very hard on
myself i am constantly trying to put out
something better than the last thing i
did and when i put out something worse
than the last thing i did that's not
good for my for my soul so i avoided my
channel for six years because i was
scared
i started posting every saturday and i
just saw the growth and it was awesome
it was freaking sweet this is so much
fun i love doing this so much and if
this goes well i can do a feature film
like the whole reason i got into all of
this was to make a movie
come on guys
get pin
hooray give them hooray roommates
through and through that's right guys
right through
hip hip
i would not be okay with myself i didn't
make a feature film if i didn't put all
of these cool ideas and thoughts in my
head into the world like i would not be
cool with myself i would not be happy
with myself it's just not possible for
me to do a feature film here and there's
certainly like the worry of if i get
used to doing other stuff am i going to
be still passionate about my dreams i
don't want to see that go away that's
like really hard for me to come to terms
with
i think
i remember when i first met you guys we
all spoke on a panel together remember
that panel i must have been like 16
years old like
yeah and the vfx and stuff and you know
i used for the track as a program and
then we filmed the like shoot your
friends thing you guys had me up there
with the freaking my hair was all spiked
up but i remember when i first came out
here and you guys invited me out and i
stayed up here on your guys couch i've
learned so much from you guys i wouldn't
know how to do
any of the vfx that i know how to do if
it weren't for you guys like i was i was
a freaking noob man it was so bad dude i
still remember this was i guess three
years ago i went on a one-wheel ride and
you joined me and you're like
don't tell anyone
i think i might be getting hired at
corridor i was like what
what
we approached you to work at corridor
more than once over the course of the
last 10 years like it happened like 100
times or so so why'd you end up saying
yes eventually well i had the
opportunity to either
work on my channel or take a job with
you guys i was stuck between like
you know i wanted to do both i didn't
know which one it's always a stressful
thing where it's like
what's the right
choice
joining you guys was like the best
possible thing for myself to learn and
to grow with with you guys i mean and
also
you guys are able to pay us
you can thank jake i can thank you guys
watching this video because the reason
we're able to do stuff like that and
have benefits in 401k and health
insurance is because of everybody that
watches and supports us
it really is great working with a team
there's nothing better than
working so hard with a group of people
on something that everyone is full
synchronized on and everyone's putting
their full energy into i think you grow
and you learn through responsibility and
we all every single one of us have a ton
of responsibility here to make this
thing work so it empowers everyone here
to do a better job and to inspire others
to do a better job all around trying to
remember how long after you joined it
was until we went and shot the meemaw
video i think it was like the first year
you know we have videos that have lots
of views right but i think that might be
our best video you think so you think
mimo is the best video i think the mom
might be the best video i think that
shot of you running out dropping your
glasses and the tank exploding out
through the wall is one of the best
shots i've ever gotten oh my god yeah i
know that was
freaking incredible man remember that
time you brought kimchi into the studio
in a little bottle and it like was like
that was that was week one yeah that was
when i called jake into the back room
and he was like
dude it smells like that stuff i don't
eat at korean restaurants
dude i remember that i remember when you
took so much oregano oil that you
smelled like a pizza
oh no hey guys hey what's up jake how
you doing jake how are you good man
we're uh we're just sitting down on the
couches just chatting okay great yeah
i'm really glad that you guys are taking
that time
i feel like
your contributions to corridor have been
spectacular and i hope there's more to
come in the future
and with stronger data protection
internet without borders and lightning
fast connectivity i feel like we can do
all that that's that's so crazy that you
said that because i'm literally gonna
say the same thing today's episode is
brought to you by expressvpn it's a core
digital tradition this is a sponsor
segment well of course today's sponsor
is expressvpn carmichael i've heard
expressvpn has award-winning templates
no that's squarespace there's two main
things that a vpn like expressvpn gives
you yeah
the first thing that it gives you is is
the ability to unblock content you know
netflix being the foremost example you
can sign in from anywhere in the world
using expressvpn and you get a whole
different selection of content because
of that for example if i wanted to watch
south park it's not available on netflix
in the us but it is available on netflix
in the uk so all i need to do is switch
my location and i now have access to
south park and hundreds of other movies
and shows you also get way more internet
privacy and security you know there's a
lot of hackers a lot of elite hack
stores out there and you don't want to
have your internet wide open for them to
just grab willy-nilly if you were
passing a note in class right you
wouldn't you wouldn't want the teacher
to read it out loud heard it's just a
risk that you don't need to take you you
get bonus internet security and you can
switch up your country to get bonus
content they have 24 7 customer support
and because they have servers all over
the world it's extremely fast it's one
of the fastest vpn services out there
how would one go about
getting access to this expressvpn go to
expressvpn.com
you could spell that out for me just to
be sure yeah yeah that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
corridor crew yeah and and if you go to
that guess what here's the kicker
you can get three months free if you
sign up for a year now that's that's a
steal dude that's less than 10 bucks a
month for a yearly subscription of
expressvpn jake i you know honestly from
the bottom of my heart i am just
grateful i i don't know what i would do
without
without these three months free of
expressvpn jake thank you so much i love
you i appreciate you all right bye jake
love you
he does that i'm never prepared whenever
he calls me for a brand segment if jake
didn't do a brand integration then
something would be wrong so i think he's
processing all right so out of
everything you've done here at corridor
what was your single
favorite thing that you've done ah so
much stuff has gone down you guys let me
on fire
[Music]
vfx source react is like one of the most
fun things for me because we get to just
hang out and like talk about awesome vfx
shots that we all love the first vfx are
just reactive so it sucks so much
it's so bad
it's so janky and like it's like it
looks it seems like an unfinished like
v1 edit hopefully
i thought i figured i just had to say
something to anything the boss town
videos i'm the most proud of those
videos for sure i'm the most proud of
the bosstown videos like that that was
so much fun to do i spent so much time
texturing and making it look legit and
doing the the surface imperfections and
everything and like i don't i don't want
to say achieve final form but i'm pretty
close like basically fooled everyone
into believing that these things are
real boss town boston dynamics corridor
digital on youtube is the guys that keep
that make it quarter the crew is the
youtube channel i think it's incredible
but it's not real so clint now you're on
your way out i feel like this is the
perfect time to ask what's the biggest
[ __ ] up that we never heard about
oh like what did i hide this one you
guys don't know about wait really should
i even i don't even do this has been
forbidden for so long the work was done
all right let's just say that the work
was done and me and dean
after lunch
played smash bros
and then we didn't stop playing until
the day was over
and we played smash bros for like four
hours a day clint dean still works here
like it was bad it was bad that sounds
so fun
sam sam
no i'm just thinking if i was in your
position i was totally doing the same
thing
oh man it's just it's been a blast
hanging out with you guys doing goofy
wacky crap man like what a ride it's
been in the last three years with your
arrival in the corridor
the golden era i think of corridor
started like we really came to our own
as a as a studio
when you joined us you've been there
since the beginning watching us on our
journey but then you're part of that
journey that means a lot man like it's
been a freaking ride and i know i'll be
back for more videos you guys aren't
going to see the last of me here what
are you most afraid of as you go out to
do your own thing that it's not going to
work you know i'm i'm betting on myself
that it's gonna work and if it doesn't
at the end of the day i can get a job at
mcdonald's rise through the ranks become
the manager and like move on to the
regional manager
and then i freaking have a burger chain
i think one thing i'm scared about it's
literally what happened to me
the first time i started my channel
which was
everything i put out has to be better
than the last thing i put out
and my like my bar of like detail and
quality was set so high
ultimately i stopped making stuff
that is one of my biggest fears that
that's gonna happen again is that i'm
just gonna like cap myself and say like
i can't put this out because it's not
good enough i mean i'm reminded of when
i was talking to snoop dogg about tupac
[Music]
no no i'm serious actually
when i was talking to snoop dogg about
tupac and he said tupac taught him
to do it every day because you love it
keep doing it and doing it and then let
the engineers mix it and master it and
not fall in love with it but fall in
love with the craft of being able to do
it and continue to do it so you can do
the same thing and i'm doing because
that's an old man if i'm doing it he was
a young man you got three steps to go
ahead and beat me at it so go ahead and
get to it and do it and if you're doing
it because you love it then you do it
consistently and if you do it
consistently then you get good yeah
consistency
i learned here that consistency is like
the most important thing
being forced to see it through with a
deadline and a crew around you
and a process like guys video comes out
on saturday you know that every saturday
videos are coming out you have to finish
it you can't stop you can't give up if
you get bogged down on oh it's not good
enough i'm not gonna put it out well
then you're not consistently working
you're not consistently working on your
craft sometimes
what you think is good is less about
like what
is good but just simply your fear of
failure whatever mistakes big or small
you make on one thing you learn from
them and the next time you do it they're
going to be better it's going to be an
improvement because you're iterating on
your past experiences the more
experiences you can iterate upon
the more the overall bar of quality
rises
it's more important to put it out learn
your lesson from it and do the second
one that's definitely something i'm
taking to heart as i go off we weren't
ready for it to say goodbye just like
you're not
er
no
unlike you who is who is ready
the person i was when i came to corridor
and the person i am now
are very different people it's not easy
to tell some of your best friends and
the people who have put a lot of
investment and trust into you and tell
them hey guys i'm i'm going i need to go
and do my own thing like that's not an
easy thing to do it's going to be a
bummer that clint's not going to be
around anymore i'm going to miss his
energy oh clint i have to say you always
have some kind of way of putting a smile
on people's face being positive clint is
hyped about everything that you're
currently working on either in your
personal life or in your professional
life he really cares he's a very big
personality that i'm going to miss it's
you're going to be able to tell that
he's gone i'm going to miss the hype
energy that's always coming from this
direction it's been such a blast working
with you here especially just like
getting amped when we're cranking on
like late nights i'm gonna miss that i'm
gonna have to get peter to do push-ups
or something honestly clint's like my
hero when i was 12 years old i
watched cardboard warfare that video
literally was the thing that told me
like oh you can make videos being able
to work with him for two years now it's
been one of the coolest opportunities in
my life i consider clint to be one of my
best friends clint and i get along on a
level that i feel like i don't with
pretty much anyone else i know it's like
our minds are on like the same sort of
vibe train right i've got some in my eye
are you crying no
i'm not
i've known clint for a long time we've
been friends for a long time and he is
one of the most genuine infectiously
excited people and we've always talked
about making feature films he's leaving
to follow his passion if he feels like
he can't do that here right now then
make it happen elsewhere when things
start changing you have to follow that
path and do what feels right i'm very
proud for clint to be able to you know
pursue his own path in life it's really
hard to make it out there as an artist
and i'm kind of proud that you're just
making it happen he's a good friend of
mine and i'm going to miss him a lot so
best of luck clint clinton if i don't
see you for a while um i just really
really want you to have this
psych i feel like there's probably going
to be a reaction of sadness amongst you
guys clint's no longer going to be at
corridor here's the truth of course he's
still going to be around you guys will
see him around he's going to be hanging
out with us outside of work either way
this is just another phase of our
friendship here and i'm really excited
to see where it goes so you'll be seeing
him every so often on react still he'll
be in you know the vfx experiment videos
that we'd love to shoot so don't be sad
be happy be proud of clint i am
friggin love you guys i'll miss you guys
i'm just going i'm i'll just be next
door seriously if you guys want to pop
your head in and see what's going on
grow your skills or even just learn a
new craft come join me over on my
channel subscribe if you guys want to
there's a link right down below you guys
want to go i actually made a video just
for you guys i try to ask myself if you
guys wanted to learn vfx what effect
would you want to learn so naturally i
went with how to turn yourself into a
robot i'm breaking down everything for
you guys to turn yourself into a
photorealistic walk-in talking robot
just like we did for boss town dynamics
come find me at youtube.com punisher